writing songs seven it was great and fun
but it was really really difficult
without knowing some sort of instrument
and so that's why I started with the
piano well I really what I really want
to do is play the drums but my my drum
teacher wouldn't teach me until I took
two years of Panos I took two years of
piano
then I took drums I got bored with drums
and then think it's picked up the guitar
and then found that the guitar and I had
this magical bond that we just can't
separate I've kind of always known I
wanted to do it and then there was that
time going through high school we're
kinda like searching for yourself it's
trying to figure out who you are and I'm
like oh well being a musician isn't
really realistic and then I started
posting videos on YouTube because I come
from like a really really small town
with a thousand people and I have six
siblings well there's another six
children I have five siblings but uh
there wasn't any option to like up and
move and so I decided to start posting
YouTube videos and then it kind of just
took off and I started getting calls
from people and oh my go I must be doing
something right even though it's just a
crappy camera from my bedroom and so
from there I just decided to pour
everything into it and tries hard like
mint for it and I've been lucky to
always have the support of my parents
which i think has made a huge difference
it started out as just a necessity
that's all that I you know had was
YouTube and then it turned into this
amazing place where I can interact
personally with bands and and then it
became this thing where you know I'm
building this from the ground up but
it's my baby and it's my project and
just a sense of like ownership and I
created this and started from nothing
nestled amazing thing about YouTube is
that you can be you know a little girl
hits town of a thousand people and you
can still go after your dreams I mean I
definitely want to find a way to take
the music and make it mainstream but I
also I definitely want to keep going
with YouTube I never want to stop
posting videos every two because that's
just where I started and I feel like it
would be an absolute mistake just like
think oh well now it's I'm not
mainstream you know YouTube's not
mainstream where and it's like you could
be mainstream and YouTube in my opinion
I think that mainstream is nervous I
think they're really nervous about the
fact that anybody on YouTube anybody in
the world can post a video and with the
you know right video or right reaction
from crowd that they could be just as
like on the same relevance level as
somebody's mainstream
my music style would be it's a little
different I do this thing on my channel
where I take rap songs and then I put
melodies to them and so that's that
hip-hop rap has kind of now like you
know sown its way into my music and so I
have like a singer/songwriter hip hop
hop kind of sound this one goes out to
my brother he's going to be deploying
soon so this one is for you Jordan
I'm not afraid to it take a stand
everybody come take my hand we'll walk
this road together through the storm
whatever weather cold or warm just think
it's all day not alone I like it still
feel like you been down the same road
you can so my brother he was leaving for
Iraq and his favorite artist was Eminem
and so I thought why not do when I'm in
heaven song for him like I had no idea
what but what I was doing is I took this
song and I just switched up the de
melody and made the lyrics clean and
then I posted on YouTube and it happened
to be you know went pretty viral I mean
at that time for me it went pretty viral
and was my first like wow this is you
know something that people really really
like and I love to do it how can he
think why I recently I got a boyfriend
he's awesome very much like him but I
also have family and I just moved out
this summer so like just just things
like that just it was funny when even
just a year ago I was like I don't know
why it you know like like some people
don't maintain their Facebook like it's
not that hard to like you know do two
posts a day or whatever and then when I
got a boyfriend and moved out and my god
I got a life I'm like oh when you have a
life it's like really right it's really
hard to keep up with some of these
things so it's a yeah it's helped with
the Maddie side of things
I is made of memory short
yeah
obviously the very same person but I
mean Maddie
growing up I was I'm such a tomboy I
mean I like playing video games I like
nerdy board games I like chemistry so I
mean I'm just this like total nerdy
geeky tomboy and then like last year was
my first year starting to wear makeup
because I you know started looking at
myself in the video so I'm like oh you
know to be what I want to be I need to
look the part so then I started getting
earlier and I really love my dresses now
so I get to be tomboy and princess well
I mean well first off you keeps giving
me the the greatest gift of being able
to do what I've literally dreamed of
since I was in diapers just I mean like
singing Disney songs you know I want and
what I want much more than this
preventor life I had no idea what I was
singing at the time but just allows me
to go after my dreams and still be able
to be myself and well and also to be my
own boss I mean who doesn't want to be
their own boss Oh
to me it's just important to stay very
very honest with myself Who I am my
music and just do it for the sake of
making awesome music I never wanted to
be about anything besides that and to me
I think that that will make the
difference in what my music sounds like
it turns out like and who I end up
working with then because I just want to
work with people who want to make
awesome music so they've definitely been
opportunities where you go you know is
it about the money is it about the the
influence is it about whatever it's
about and then you have to I just step
back and be like is this the best move
for the music at the end no matter what
is on the table or what's being offered
it has to be best for projects that I've
been growing from where I come from
money doesn't I guess mean the same
thing as it does in other places and for
me money has never been to anything that
Fame is not why I'm doing this money is
not why I'm doing this and for me to
know those things that matter to me
obviously I'm very very grateful that my
youtube career is now at the point where
I can support myself just off the music
I used to work at a nursing home and I
got to quit that last year and I'm so
grateful for that and I hope that I will
continue to be able to support myself
it's that way but it's what I just love
the music I'm gonna quit
hey guys Madeline Bailey here thank you
so much for checking on my interview
with new media rockstars you should head
over their website to check out the full
video also I have a youtube channel
I have Facebook Twitter so check me out
there for more see you later
so much